nietzsche has this thought experiment
called a turnover currents
where you
get to relive your whole life over and
over and over and over and i think it's
a way to
bring to the surface of your mind the
idea that every single moment in your
life matters
it intensely matters the bad and the
good and he kind of wants you to
imagine that idea that every single
decision you make throughout your life
you repeat over and over and over and he
wants you to respond to that do you feel
horrible about that or do you feel good
about that and you have to
think through this idea in order to see
where you stand in life how you what is
your relationship like with life i
actually want to read his the way he
first introduces that concept
for people who are not familiar
what if some day or night a demon by the
way he has a demon introduced this
thought experiment
what if some day or night a demon were
to steal after you into your loneliest
loneliness
and say to you
quote this life as you now live it and
have lived it you will have to live once
more and innumerable times more and
there will be nothing new in it but
every pain and every joy and every
thought and sigh and everything
unutterably small and great in your life
will have to return to you all in the
same succession and sequence would you
not throw yourself down and gnash your
teeth and curse the demon who spoke thus
or
have you once experienced the tremendous
moment when you would have answered him
you are a god and never have i heard
anything more divine
so are you terrified or excited about
such a thought experiment when you
applied to your own life excited
excited oh even the dark stuff oh yeah
for sure definitely i mean also that
thing you're talking about it he he kind
of leaves out
maybe on purpose because the thought
experiment starts falling apart a little
bit yeah the amnesia between each loop
so
you know the whole thing gets wiped now
if the amnesia wasn't there and yet
somehow you were
witnessing the non-autonomy
implicit in what he's talking about so
you have to kind of watch yourself go
through this rotten loop then yeah
that's a description there's probably a
boredom that comes into that so you
don't experience everything anew exactly
the best stuff the good stuff the
newness of it is really important that's
it yeah this is the uh
in the in hades when you die you
there's a river i think it's called leaf
you ever heard of this l-e-t-h-e you
drink from it and you don't remember
your past lives and then when you're
reborn it's fresh and you don't have to
i mean just think of like the amount of
psychological help you would need to get
over all the [ __ ] that happened in
prior lives
can you imagine if you're still
resentful
of something someone did to you in the
14th century
but it would it would compound well if
you repeat the same thing over and over
and over
there would be no difference maybe you
would start to appreciate the nuances
more like when you watch the same movie
over and over and over yeah maybe you'll
get the
actually
[Music]
let go this idea of all the possible
all the positive possibilities that lay
before you but actually enjoy the moment
much more if you remember that you've
lived this life a thousand times all the
little things the way somebody smiles
uh if you're been abused the way
somebody like the pain of it yeah the
the suffering the down that you feel the
experience of sadness depression fear
all that kind of stuff you get to really
uh you get to also appreciate that
that's part of life yeah part of being a
life
now also in his experiment if i was
gonna and i love the experiment from the
perspective of like just where
technology is now and simulation theory
and stuff like that but
in that in that thought experiment if
this rotten demon
immediately killed you
then within that it's a little more
horrifying because
even in the
first of all you're trusting a [ __ ]
demon why are you talking to a demon
yeah you start there yeah that because
that is going to be even before i get
into like the metaphysics and like the
implications and where is this life
stored where's the loop stored i mean
are we talking about some kind of
unchanging data set or something before
that you're like why is there a [ __ ]
talking demon in my room trying to freak
me out
you're gonna want to autopsy the demon
can you catch it does this apply to you
demon and again obviously it's a [ __ ]
thought experiment nietzsche would be
annoyed by me but i think like you would
still be able to entertain
the
joy you'd have the joy of not knowing
what's around the corner you know still
it's not like you know what's coming
just because the demon said some kind of
loop in other words the idea of being
damned to your past decisions
it doesn't even work because you can't
remember what decisions you're about to
make
so from from that perspective also i
think i'd be happy about it or i would
just think oh cool i mean it's a good
story i'm going to tell people about how
this i wonder what the demon would
actually look like in real life because
i suspect it would look like
like a charming like a friend
wouldn't wouldn't they be a loved one
wouldn't the demon come to you
through the mechanism through the front
door of love not to the back door
of evil
like malevolent manipulation sure i mean
if it's the truth
if it's the truth then that's
whether it's love or not it's still good
fundamentally
i do like the idea of the memory replay
i remember i went to a newer link event
a few years ago
and got to hang out with elon
i remember how visceral it is that
there's like a pig
with the neural link
in it
and you're talking about memory replays
as a future maybe far future possibility
and you realize well this is a very
meaningful moment in my life
this could be a replay like of all the
things you replay it's probably
you know there's certain magical moments
in your life whatever whatever it is
certain people you've met for the first
time
or certain things you've done for the
first time with certain people or not
just an awesome thing you did and i
remember just saying to him like i would
probably want to replay this
at
this moment and yeah it just seemed very
kind of
i mean there was a recursive nature to
it but it seemed
very real that this is something you
would want to do with that
the richness of life could be
experienced through the replay that's
probably where it's experienced the most
like you could see life as a way to
collect a bunch of cool memories and
then you get to sit back in your nice vr
headset and replay the cool ones that's
right
this is in buddhism you know the the
idea that like i struggle with is that
there's a possibility
of not reincarnating of not coming back
that's the idea like you this is the
this is suffering here the suffering is
caused by attachment
and so
if you like revise
the idea of reincarnation or
the
nietzsche's loop
and look at it from
could this be possible or how would this
be possible technologically
then to me it makes a lot of sense like
i've been thinking a lot about this very
thing and nietzsche's idea connecting to
it i had this like
it sounds so dumb but i was at the
dentist getting nitrous oxide high as a
[ __ ] kite man and i had this idea
i was thinking about data i was thinking
like
man probably if i had to bet there's
some energetic form that we're not aware
of that for a super advanced technology
would be as
detectable as like starlight but
something that we just don't even know
what it is
quantum turbulence who the [ __ ] knows
fill in the blank whatever that x may be
but assuming that exists that somehow
data even the most subtle things the
tiniest movements whatever it may be the
uh emanations of your neurological
process energetically whatever it may be
is radiating out into space-time then
what if like the james webb version of
this for some advanced civilization is
not that they're like looking at the
nebula or whatever but they're actually
able to peer into the past and via some
bizarre technology recreate whatever
life simulate whatever life was
happening there just by decoding that
quantum energy whatever it is i'm always
saying quantum because it's what dumb
people say when they don't know you just
say quantum i don't know but you don't
even
you're decoding that so meaning you know
in simulation theory one of the big
questions that pops up is
why and are we in one and
elon has talked about well it's probably
more of a probability than we're in one
then we're not in which case what you're
talking about
is actually happening that that loop
you're talking about it's we've decided
to be here we this of all the things
we decided this one oh let's do that one
again i want to do that one let's try
let's do that that's
i love thinking about this because like
i love my family yeah and it makes sense
to me that if i'm going to replay some
life or another it's definitely going to
be this one with my kids my wife with
all the [ __ ] that's gone along with
it i'm still gonna want to come back so
in buddhism that's attachment yeah but
you weren't the one or you're saying
you're the main player you're not the
mpc well i think we're dealing with all
npcs at this point i mean depending on
how you want to like very i would say
very advanced npcs like incredibly
advanced
npcs compared to uh fallout or something
you know we've got a lot of conversation
options happening here
there's not like four things you can
pick from yeah but there's a whole uh
illusion of free will that's happening
we really do
depending where you are in the world
feel like you're free to decide any
trajectory in your life that you want
which is pretty funny right for an npc
is pretty it's nice
you